Jeepers Creepers introduced horror fans
to the creeper a movie monster with a
unique story every 23 years it wakes
from hibernation for exactly 23 days
during those 23 days it eats human body
parts which gruesomely go on to form its
body as frightening as that premise is
it'd be wasted if not performed by a
talented actor fortunately the creeper
has Jonathan Breck in its Corner Breck
appears as the creeper in the Jeepers
Creepers films it's by far his most
famous role as he hasn't done much
recognizable work outside of the
franchise he's appeared in films ranging
from Spy Kids 4 all the Time in the
World to Parkland though never in a role
as prominent as the one he plays in the
Jeepers Creepers franchise Breck may not
be a household name but will always be
happy or terrified to see him suit up as
the creeper